et pour en parler nous sommes avec
thomas montagne président de la
confédération européenne des vignerons
indépendants thomas montagne bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation le salon wine bar in vino
vinexpo pardon se déroule donc on le
disait dans un climat morose entre les
taxes le coronavirus le bric site
bref est ce que ce type de salon est un
moyen une occasion de relancer les
exportations
est ce que ça fonctionne oui en général
ça fonctionne assez bien et je pense que
ce qu'il faut dire sur ce salon c'est
que pour la première fois nous avons en
france un salon unitaire l'ensemble de
la france viticole se retrouvent à paris
alors que jusqu'à présent ces dernières
années nous étions éclaté en trois
quatre cinq salons différents ce qui
était ce qui rendait les choses très
compliquées notamment pour les
importateurs au grand export pour venir
nous voir alors que vous aviez en
allemagne un grand salon unique à
düsseldorf qui drainait énormément de
monde donc nous sommes très contents
d'avoir ce salon maintenant unitaire qui
se tient à paris justement alors
effectivement salon interprofessionnelle
toutes les interprofessions française un
vin de loire côtes-du-rhône bordeaux
alsace vous êtes tous réunis vous venez
de le dire c'est quoi l'idée derrière la
stratégie c'est l'union fait la force
certainement je pense que il faut que
nous apprenions mais c'est valable pour
d'autres secteurs d'air en france de
l'économie française nous apprenons
davantage à chasser en meute ou tout
simplement profiter économies génèrent
de d'échelle et puis je vous le disais
vraiment avoir plus de poids pour faire
venir nos clients jusqu'ici on les fait
venir une fois peut-être deux fois par
an en france on l'aimé pas dire quatre
fois par an en france notamment une fois
à montpellier autrefois bordeaux a fait
une fois en val de loire et c'est dans
cette cité a justifié alors je le
rappelle quelques chiffres en novembre
aux états unis les exportations de vins
français se sont effondrées de 44% par
rapport au mois d'octobre après ces
femmes staxyn de 25% de l'administration
trump est ce que l'heure est à la
panique qui aujourd'hui chez les
vignerons français panique c'est
peut-être bien grand mot mais une forte
inquiétude
évidemment parce que ceux qui ne se vend
pas
à l'export se retrouvent sur le marché
français ipso facto ce sont des
équilibres qui sont assez fragiles on
est on est sur un marché peu élastique
donc une légère surproduction enfin sur
quantité d'offres par rapport à la
demande peut faire chuter les cours de
manière assez importante et émettre
toute la pyramide malvy en vous lisiez
tout l'interprofession réunit justement
un pour eux pour contrer un petit peu
ces difficultés là qu'elles sont
finalement les autres pistes à mettre en
oeuvre pour vous pour relancer les
exportations de vins français
écoutez si on parle sur cette histoire
de taxes d'abord ce qui nous paraît nous
absolument inadmissible et ce que nous
voulons pas voir se reproduire jamais
c'est d'être les victimes collatérales
les otages
la viticulture le monde viticole
français et européens finalement parce
que ça touche plus largement que la
france est prise en otage par des choses
qui n'étaient pas totalement en
l'occurrence aucune histoire qui date de
2004 une plainte devant l'om c'est
concernant du problème entre boeing et
airbus et moi mais c'est pas notre
affaire
vous avez sans le sentiment finalement
de payer des conséquences d'une guerre
qui n'est pas la vôtre
ah oui dommage collatéral voilà ce que
nous sommes et ça nous va pas du tout du
tout le président macron pourtant on le
sait est un amateur de vin davantage que
les précédent d'ailleurs est ce
que vous sentez soutenu aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement par le chef d'état a
écouté je ne sais pas parce que ou oui
mais oui et non parce qu'il y avait
aussi ce problème de taxes gafa dont on
savait que ça allait poser que trump
allait réagir d'ailleurs il a réagi et
ce faisant il a obligé monsieur macron a
reculé
dont acte pour le moment mais c'est
quelque chose qu'ils reportaient enfin
on parlait là d'une taxe non pas de 25%
mais de 100% sur un certain nombre de
produits franco français donc c'était
cet invraisemblable
parce que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
je sais pas seulement le coût de la taxe
la limite 25 % peut-être que certains
sont en capacité en la partageant avec
l'importateur delà de la
le payer mais on perd des parts de
marché
parce qu'on est on s'éloigne des
linéaires on a quand même réussir à peu
près 80% de nos vignerons en france je
parle venir les vignerons indépendants
adhérents ont honte eu à choisir lé dire
la vérité ou le cercueil c'est à dire
soit entre une prise en charge pour
partie ou totalité du surcoût de 25 %
soit la commande est reporté sine die
voilà ce qui se passe actuellement
quand une commande est reporté jeudi
d'autres que nous l'apprennent pour
l'instant ça se passe en dehors d'europe
c'est ce sont des australiens des
chiliens des argentins et c'est qu'ils
bouffent des parts de marché part de
marché c'est difficile à gagner ça se
perd très vite mais pour la regagner
après c'est compliqué donc c'est pour ça
que nous nous demandons avec insistance
et de manière très rapide est ce que
l'europe et les européens puissent
mettre en place un fonds bed qui
permettent de passer ce cap rapidement
et puis au delà de ça bien entendu il
faudrait que au niveau européen encore
une fois on sera en capacité de répondre
de manière unitaire et demi au problème
de monsieur très justement vous êtes
vous le président de la confédération
européenne des vignerons indépendants
il y aura vous le disiez tout à l'heure
un autre salon du vin ce sera à
düsseldorf cette fois ci
un sérieux concurrent finalement et vous
appeler à l'unité justement entre les
vignerons de toute l'europe pour faire
face à la fois aux taxes de trump mais
aussi aux autres problématiques
commerciales
oui bah c'est un petit peu le but de
tout syndicat est donc la confédération
européenne que je préside ces gens
représentent quoi moi j'en compte à peu
près 200 mille petites entreprises très
petites entreprises au niveau européen
ça fait ça fait quand même du monde
on a treize états membres qui sont
adhérents à notre confédération
le vigneron indépendant c'est qui c'est
celui qui fait tout de a jusqu'à z dans
la filière c'est à dire qui il a cet
agriculteur qui a ses vignes qui les
cultivent c'est un transformateur qui va
faire du vin avec ses propres réseaux et
c'est un commerçant km ce vin en marché
donc il a un métier très vaste le
corollaire c'est que il produit beaucoup
de valeur ajoutée dans les territoires
où il est et il a un fort impact donc au
niveau environnemental au niveau du
maintien des territoires de moteurs en
bon état environnemental et économique
donc quand on on touche nous entrons
touche nos petites entreprises on
attaque vite quelque chose est
fondamental dans les territoires ruraux
pour ça qu'on est important en fait la
souffrance de ces vignerons indépendants
elle est surtout en france où partout en
europe
elle s'exprime tels des différentes mais
sur le sujet qui nous préoccupe la les
taxes
curieusement alors que bavaria cinq pays
qui se veut quatre en quatre pays qui
sont touchés par les taxes sur le vin
notamment la france
l'italie ne l'est pas en principe ne
supporte pas actuellement cet acte 25%
pour autant je sais je sais que mes mais
mes confrères et amis italiens sont
aussi dans l'expectative des perdre
aussi des parts de marché parce que vous
savez que le business horreur de
l'incertitude et très peu à tout moment
décider de modifier cet état de chose il
y avait maintenant c'est plus de la
france et les vins italiens un container
de vins italiens qui se trouverait entre
sur la mer en transit pour les états
unis pourraient être en partie alizés
rotax arrivé là-bas avec 25 % de taxes
je vous dis pas le bazar pour payer un
autre mot donc évidemment pour les
italiens aussi il va les importateurs
américains sont en standby pro moment il
ya eu six le break site on en a beaucoup
parlé est ce que vous avez une
visibilité vous comme vigneron pour la
suite pour les exportations futures en
direction du royaume uni vraiment je
sais comme tout le monde que l'on nous
promet un ordre de stabilité
immédiatement après j'espère quand même
qu'avec nos amis anglais on va réussir à
s'entendre c'est pour nous français
c'est partir mais important puisque
entre les états unis et numéro 1 pour
notre marché et les anglais numéro 2 on
a du pain sur la planche et si on
rajoute le problème chinois vous évoquez
tout à l'heure avec le coronavirus
évidemment notre quoi être inquiet alors
justement pour conclure face à ces
inquiétudes est ce que vous comptez vous
mobiliser pour en appeler à l'europe ou
gouvernement surtout à l'europe je pense
c'est un problème européen
et oui oui je le redis hors de question
pour nous pour la viticulture me plante
je pense pour l'agriculture en général
que nous soyons quasi systématiquement
les victimes collatérales de problèmes
qui ne dépasse totalement
voilà merci beaucoup thomas montagne
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes président de la
confédération européenne des vignerons
indépendants
merci à vous